[Music]
so I started learning this suite today
and there are a few points that I want
to make about Bach in general and
especially this piece so on first glance
just seems like there are three parts
base that middle voice and then the top
line which are sixteenth notes
I think contained within the right hand
there are at least three things going on
so I hear this part
[Music]
I also here
[Music]
so on and so forth also contained in the
middle is this line
[Music]
so even though on first glance it just
looks like a line with sixteenth notes
there's a lot going on in there so why
did I single out those lines because
they're either in step motion
they were implying some sort of harmony
and they were very simple to sing so if
I were to take this line and I had a
choice of assigning all these notes to
different singers I would choose three
and those would be the lines I think
[Music]
you
[Music]
so what I'm hearing in these lines be
very well change but I just wanted to
give you an idea of what I'm listening
to as it now on the first day that I'm
working on this and I'd be curious to
see how I hear it in a week's time or a
month's time or a year's time so anyway
that was it I will keep working on this
and I will see you soon
[Music]
[Music]